in this capsule we will see
the max mini algorithm then the notation
we're going to use is we're going
firstly refer to
first players as the player
max is the second player so on
the opponent as being the player mines
we will also interpret the result
of a party as being the like
result the distribution of a
reward to max players so the
reward it could be the result
of a bet or a maxi mines would have
contributed money then the winner gets
would get the amount amassed by
so money contributes by max and by
mean so max have chosen the word max
because mac is obviously want
maximize his reward and midnight to
the reverse will want to minimize the
reward of max and that's because
that we are a context of a sum game
no, therefore, since mines will receive
the opposite of the max reward he's going
want and obviously minimize the
reward of max so more so
concrete maybe the reward for
mac that to be money
5 dollars and so so what was
returned as reward a max of
secondary 5 is that max would get 5
dollars after the party because we
can have a negative reward of 5
$ in this case it would mean that
does mine would get $ 5 so max
lose 5 dollars
so as for the problems that we have
tried to solve with to star we're going
to start by determining what is the
structure of the research space we
will explore to get a solution to
our problem and is able to
design is a player in a two-game
opponents
so we will see again as
in the star is not it that's going
to match a graph that we are going to explore
but in what if we do kirov in
question will match a tree on
does not match the initials that correspond
at the initial configuration of the game as
in the story will also have a
transition function that will us
return a list of our successors
and there in the context of dangerous
opponents will make explicit the
concept of an action associates onu
successor
the relationship between the two is that the
successor nephew this is the knot that is
done on all roofs that results from
the execution of the action that is given
with the naked successor see also a
termination test that allows
to identify his hyper v at the end of a
part so today a role similar to
the goal function of to stars but in
more about a utility function for them
final states that will give us the
reward received by the player so has
that the quantity that is maximized by
max players and that is minimized by
the player then mines our space from
search will bring together those here in a
example of tick-to-toe we will see in
what we actually observe is for
each one we have a grid of
tic-tac-toe
with some configuration so at
the initial state we will see a grid that
is completely empty and the others
have to match a kerry with
x and waters
so for the initial state will be associated
max turn since it's max that play
first and then the next step
associated with mine players when if one
used x for max and waters
for mym now the function of
transition she will determine what are
the successor nodes we see a
successor by possible action so
following the initial state max can do
one of the different factions going to see
nine actions nine successor states
possible
each partner with a position of x
different and and recurrently
we will be able to apply the function of
transition on these states where the ca goes
match the node to the mym player who
will he place a bone in the grid and
so more
for example this state there too we would have
in fact 8 draws successor possible so
eight different positions for the round
be here here here and instituted and
notice that for the second the
successor to the initial state
we would also have eight others
transition possible so growth
exponential of the number of possible states
of the game and if we continue like that in
applying the transition function of
recurring way we eventually go
arrive at final states that are going
have associated utility so what is
returned by our utility function
have a negative value if these mines
who gang
because if they chose - 1 pass
as if the max player was losing indolent
6000 win we'll see possibly
value of 0.6 on equal our code of
tact game one can have equality is
besides positive +1 6 and the player x
who wins the game
so notice that this structure there one
recursively apply the function
transition that corresponds to a tree so
each name is associated with only one parent
he also notices that the nodes
final are at depths
possibly different so in this
case also the depth of that
corresponds to a depth of 1 2 3 4 5
6 since six actions that was played
is being discussed in depth
9 so this draw was nine transition
from the final state the initial state forgiveness in
emitting ready to watch the algorithm
minimax so the main idea behind
the mini max algorithm knows we're going
to assume that the most profitable action
is always taken by the max player or
the player mines when his rate is at
to say that the player maxou the player mines
will take the value mines max the most
profitable
so we will define this notion of
minimax value the max min value in
the hand will correspond to three cases of
figure the first is the body or n
is an endless
when if the max mini speech is going to be
simply the utility associated with this
terminal 2nd final so it's the collar the
simpler than initial now seems
that's how recursively we're going
set the min max value of one in
for the case where it is an axis like
being the max min value of a premium em
or a premium and a successor who
maximizes this minimax value there so that
it translates a little more formal way
the fact that the max player wants to maximize
the minimum value what will be obtained
after doing the action that
corresponds to our successors between and
the same way if n matches
players mines the player mine earns him
crohn
the action that corresponds to our
successors a bonus whose value
mini max is minimal
so these equations the federation end up
finally a recursive program that goes
allow us to calculate the value
mini max up to the root ie
we will apply until
reach 1 the finally so our programs
recursively implicitly behind there
the tree and when will we go tears
we will begin by reaching
eventually the kids and then we go
can make up the minimum value
upward axes
via these recursion equations there so
we have here the minimax algorithm
that is to say the algorithm that chooses
the action that allows to get for the
max player the action who have the best
max min value then when calling
mini max we give the initial name
where the max player has to take an action
and what a mini max is going to return
it's the action will turn by a
mute tomax what toro max does
this correspondence formerly
the action taken by the max player when
this is its rate in the state n
so firstly if it corresponds to
an end of the game makes the player max
can not play it just goes
return the utility m to those of that we will
initialize the value of uts units
Russia we are not at the end of the game at
less defined I am in association a
action that is a null pointer and we're going
hyper and on all actions and their
associated successor states that so
all the actions that can take the
max player is what we will do is
what are we going to call what is the value
max max associated with the successor state in
premium and specifically to greens goes
call what is the result of the turn
following mine player mines and if
this value there is greater than
current utility in our iteration
well we will affect the action that will be
taken by max like and at action to
so let's pray in initialized in utah - is
over it that's for sure we're going at least
choose an action since the values
go back here go will necessarily
bigger than less than a movie and we're going
obviously affect there after having
assigned the action if it was an action
who got better utility
we will remember this utility there and
once we max that will reconsider
all possible actions that can
to take that will find the one that has
a value a mini max so one that he
will swallow returned by mine turn that has
found the action he allowed max the
higher we will return this
laakso utility therefore befits the bar
max associates then the action
which corresponds to this obtaining this
minimax value there and so we saw that
the mute ends we have just
here in fact it's exactly the same
thing that for max towers the only
difference is that as we saw before
mines will try to minimize the value
minimum
so it's minimizing the reward
obtained by max so in this loop
here rather than maximizing we want
minimize that is to say that we will call
the minimum value is associated with the turn
next ie the player's turn
max we'll see is it's a
value smaller than the current utility
and if so, we will update
our gold action that will be considered
by the player mine this turn the pair on
will update it to value at premium
than generate that in bonus the then we go
associate as utility the utility that
we were returned the father the turn
next which is the turn of the max players
and realizing it had infinite value
we have this loop here
calculates the action that has the min max value
the smallest and finally the mute
ends going back as max utility
so the mini max value find and
action associated with getting this
minimax value here are some
properties of the imax algorithm
firstly it's an algorithm that is
complete that is to say they return
always a solution
is there always a solution under the
condition that the tree is finished so
that it is not possible to first a
part that never stops that does not
never ends
it is a magritte that is optimal but
according to two conditions that makes it very
important to know that it's a
algorithm that will turn the action
optimal to take part the max player if
the adversary
also play optimally so that
means that the great mini max is not going
to exploit weaknesses in
his opponent
the example of airlock and chess there is a
quite well known technique or if
the opponent but is placed in a
vulnerability situation it's
possible for the opponent to win the
part in capital however it's
possible for the opponent to avoid that
that happen it just does not take them
place themselves in this position of a
empowered there and since the great minimax
suppose the pair add up way
optimal in the code of the chess game he
will assume that the opponent never gets
place in a position of
vulnerability like that so the flu
mini max actually makes the one guess
worst case know that our opponent
is the best possible
and that's when making this solution there
who chooses you his action the action that
will take and his strategy
so that's a benefit to where
it's really the worst case though
if we knew that our opponent
did not know for example in case of
fail that strategy there to win in
four shots maybe that in reality we
would like an algorithm that exploits sure
but it's not with mini max that we
would see happen for that it would take in
make a certain pattern and then some
knowledge a priori richer on
what our opponent
the quality of our opponent's game
now for what complexity in
execution time of mini max it goes
run in b water to hate
so in what cbc lawyer this bridge or
no maximum legal costs at each
step and like that will match the
maximum number of moves in a game
so basically corresponds to the
maximum depth of cube tears and
corresponds to the connection factors
in notable the number of children
maximum maximum that can be generated
when searching is a way of
see how is it
exponential finally 1 m
so that's another beal complexity to m
is that each turn can generate
a number of children that corresponds to b
and the maximum number of shots that can
be executed cm
so we will see b cost possible times
possible beccu possible shots
1 located just so on until that
we arrive at
cost so at the end of the game so it's me
does indeed give b to the m
complexity in space is a lot
less worst is linear in bi am
that's because in fact the course
that we do is basically
in-depth research
so at some point when we talk
from the root we will arrive
possibly at the end of the game
so this way and their vote is of
size m then at each our
intermediaries we will have possibly
generate all possible children and this
there are some so that gives a total of one
number of nodes in memory b times m
it's possible to finally have an hour
complexity or at the same time generates at
need each of the nine so in that
if the number of draws we would have in
memory at all times would be at most
but oh really the worst worse scenery for
a deep search like that
would be at 2 bis times m what we notice
is that for a chess game
reasonable not too long
we did a branching factor b
who's going is roughly equal to 35 then a
maximum number of rates for a
particle not too long
around st and if you do the math
of
from 35 to the assembly see that it's a
pretty astronomical man
so that will match a quantity
calculation that we can not really
hope to do in a reasonable time
so the mini max flu is a
algorithm that is relatively naive
as far as it fits a
amount calculation that is way too much
serious
is what we sell in capsules
next is to comment on what we can
actually decrease that number of this
amount of calculation there is actually in
the next capture we'll see
pruning pruning alfa beta we will get
ask the question to see commented this
that we can eliminate paths in the
language they are useless to explore